[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen klassiker wobei
eigentlich 12 und zwar eine käse sahne
torte mit einem bienenstich verbunden
und das ganze an die etwa saison
angepasst
eine käse sahne etwa bienenstich torte
du hast alles reingepackt er geht nicht
mehr geht nicht
samira las und las die wasser balance da
noch liegen das machen wir gleich im
anschluss nach dem dreh ich nehme es ihr
gleich wieder weg genau der boden ist
ein richtig lockerer erteilt also eine
rührmaschine die tollen erdbeeren ihr
könnt noch nicht auch himbeeren nehmen
oder andere früchte für die torte muss
zuerst einmal die röhre wasser
hergestellt werden und dafür zeige ich
euch mal die zutaten
das hat mir die samira gemacht und wenn
die sanierung einer kette macht dann
trage ich die mit stolz und würde dies
erschwere die kelle sieht toll aus
es ist wichtig nicht nur auf die verlass
ist schön ist also höher den teig
brauche ich 71 eine prise salz 120 gramm
zucker 170 gramm weiche butter 120 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt 750
gramm mehl und etwas milch oder ein
schuss rum und für den belag 100 gramm
gehobelte mandeln 50 gramm zucker und 50
gramm sahne für die römer masse nehme
ich jetzt zuerst das eiweiß und geht es
in eine saubere und fettfreie schüssel
das ist ganz wichtig damit der schnee
auch schön fest
da kommen die krise teils dazu und die
bewirkt dass die eiweiß struktur
schneller zerstört wird und der schnee
schneller stabil ist
sobald der schnee fest ist gebe ich
jetzt noch den super ganz langsam dazu
und für die masse dann richtig fest
[Musik]
so ist perfekt so und jetzt noch flugs
der zucker im schnee bewegt übrigens
dafür ist nämlich so flott und dass man
ihn später ganz gut mit den anderen
zutaten verbinden kann das nämlich eine
zweite schüssel da kommt die weiche
butter rein puderzucker und etwas
vanille fragt jetzt kann ich die butter
zucker mischung butter zucker vanille
mischung etwa von sechs minuten richtig
cremig verrühren und zwar so lange bis
die butter richtig schön weiß schaumig
ist
[Musik]
wenn die butter masse dann weiß schauen
wir jetzt kommen die eigelbe
nacheinander dazu
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich das mail unter geben und
danach einen schluck milch könnte warum
nehmen und den einschnitt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich eine schöne
geschmeidigere maßhaltig stelle ich ganz
kurz zur seite
jetzt kommt nämlich noch der belag dann
für den bienenstich ist eine kreuzung
aus bienenstich und käse sahne torte
da bin ich jetzt die mandeln den zucker
und die sahne das wird jetzt verrührt
normalerweise koche ich die zutaten
immer auf aber hier verfügen wir jetzt
einfach mal kurz das reicht dürfte im
ofen trotzdem karamellisieren und damit
dass jetzt ein bisschen aufregender wird
gebe ich jetzt schon mal einen teil also
die hälfte etwa auf dem boden einer
plattform
dann nämlich den bug ring den habe ich
schon eingestellt auf 24 zentimeter
durchmesser vorteile ist die mandeln auf
dem boden
und da kommt an die ruhr masse darum
[Musik]
jetzt noch die restlichen mandeln und
der teig bzw
die rohe masse die braucht auch wirklich
gar kein backpulver denn die butter
wieder schön schaumig geschlagen
der schnee kommt noch dazu und dadurch
wird der teig und da nicht wird er
gucken dann auch schön locker
[Musik]
hawkins lacht rücken und ab in den ofen
der kuchen ist jetzt gebacken und ich
habe ihn komplett abkühlen lassen
ihr könnt ihr noch zum beispiel am abend
vorher zu bereiten hier am rande ist ein
bisschen was ausgelaufen das ist aber
gar nicht schlimm und bisschen was es
völlig okay
die oberfläche ist richtig schön
goldbraun und er ist wegen schon
komplett kalt jetzt kommt die käse sahne
füllung mit den erdbeeren dafür verwende
ich 600 gramm sahne sechs teelöffel
sommerbad 500 gramm quark etwas vanille
extrakt 50 computer zucker 5 täler für
sommerbad und zum bestreichen erdbeer
marmelade und zum belegen richtig schöne
erdbeeren ich werde jetzt erstmal die
creme zubereitet und dann den teig
durchschneiden
also zuerst die saale in die
rührschüssel jetzt kurz ein bisschen
rühe
und dann langsam das fahrrad pathos
und die sahne kurz steif schlagen und
hier kann ich aber auch schon mal den
quark berühren
dafür gebe ich den quark in eine
rührschüssel dann etwas vanille extrakt
dazu das schädlich vorher immer damit
sich die vanille sahne ein bisschen
verteilen gute zucker rein und das
restliche sonderfahrt und das kann ich
jetzt ganz kurz mit dem schneebesen
verrühren
[Musik]
die sahen ist steigt jetzt kann ich hier
noch den quark unterheben
das mache ich jetzt ohne küchenmaschine
denn da muss man auch aufpassen dass man
die sahne nicht so lange schlägt damit
sie nicht gewinnen
[Musik]
wenn sie gerade so fest ist das sind
nicht nur das lebt ist sie perfekt die
stelle ich kurz in den kühlschrank weil
es hier drinnen wirklich sehr warm ist
und dann kann ich schon mal den
tortenboden auslösen
[Musik]
das lege ich einen toten retter darunter
einen oben drauf und kann den boden
umdrehen
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich einmal mit der torten
säge in der mitte durch
nehme den oberen teile zweck es bleibt
aber weiterhin der boden und das ist der
deckel und den schneide ich jetzt schon
mal in kuchenstücke zu damit einfach
später die torte im anschnitt nicht
zusammengedrückt
[Musik]
den tortenboden bestreichen stets mit
etwas marmelade
da könnt ihr gern erdbeermarmelade
nehmen die passen
ich habe jetzt nur mehr frucht marmelade
weil die show auf nur
[Musik]
kaum den morgen
was überrascht wäre wieso darf später
gleich vertraut und kann in ruhe oder
kaffee
setz dich erste reihe ist für dich
reserviert ach so kriegt man doch gleich
gute stimmung oder voll kriegt man
gleich gute laune selbst die ab dann
habe ich jetzt schon geputzt und unten
gerade abgeschnitten
jetzt nimmt er immer die schönsten
erdbeeren weil es ist alles schön die
schönste werden halbiert und dann nehme
ich hier an den rand gelegt denn es
bleibt ja eine make it torte ich mache
heute unterschiedlich in der gleich zwei
gleichen nebeneinander und der rand
bleibt dann sichtbar und dann ist es
echt schön wenn man da halbe erst dann
drauf hat
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier der tortenring außen
rum und fallen die ärzte nämlich auch
nicht raus zu machen und die mitte jetzt
voll stellen mit den übrigen erdbeeren
[Musik]
darüber kommt jetzt die gläserne und
dieses bild vom bisschen rein drücken
damit sie auch wirklich bis unter die
erdbeeren geht von der tropfen creme
nämlich etwa sechs esslöffel weg und
bewahre sie für die dekoration zum
schluss im kühlschrank auf
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen die tortenstücke wieder
drauf und dann kann die torte schon in
den kühlschrank für etwa vier bis fünf
stunden oder zb über nacht
[Musik]
nach der kür zeit lese ich die torte
jetzt aus dem backhaus und setzen sie
auch direkt auf eine tortenplatte
[Musik]
dann bestehe ich sehe mit etwas süßem
schnee
und die restliche creme fühle ich jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel und spritze kleine
rosetten auf die torte und da kommen
jetzt noch mit band auf
[Musik]
und so sieht die torte jetzt aus und
wenn man sie an schneidet hat man auch
im innern richtig schön die erdbeeren
ich aber sagen du musst jetzt schnell
essen weil ich stets einer halben stunde
schon draußen und plötzlich war es fällt
mir sonst das sind 30 grad ist echt
alles eingebaut ist wie nichtig erklärt
hatte ich vergessen nein ein trüffel
sozusagen und der boden ist genial ein
echtes geheimnis dass lange lange rühren
[Musik]
dass man es ausprobieren um ihre auch
okay so trost zur legung immer mit epcam
also ich bin ja richtig lecker also
gehört auf jeden fall zu den top5 kann
ich nicht mehr sagen gibt so viele top
trocken
aber die super lecker probiert sie auf
jeden fall gerne mal aus gerade jetzt zu
etwa zeige ich darüber informierten
kreisen wichtig ist der käse noch ist
apple ist wie man alles zusammen mixen
und diese hörte gespannt darauf wer
zuerst diese torte zubereitet und ein
foto kostet auf instagram kletter-gala
[Musik]
also viel spaß beim backen und bis zum
nächsten mal
aber die muss ich den kühlschrank
ja ich geb dir noch ein stück max noch
eine erdbeere
oben drauf kommt weiß mal ab ich kann
jetzt gerne wasserbomben machen
[Musik]